i wish to reiterate the firm call i made
last week
which is indeed referring to a plausible
endgame for the pandemic
not to say
that it is now all over
but to highlight
that in the european region
there is a singular opportunity to take
control of the transmission
because
of the congruence of three elements
first
a large capital of vaccine derived and
natural immunity by omicron
second
a favorable seasonality pass
as we move out of the winter
and third
a lower severity of the omnicom variant
now well established
the european region has recorded 12
million new cases in the past week
this is the highest weekly case
incidence
since the start of the pandemic
and is largely being driven by the
highly transmissible omicron variant
as it sweeps from west to east
30 percent of all covet 19 cases
since the pandemic began
have been reported
this year alone 22
of all tests recorded are positive
hospitalizations continue to rise
mainly in countries with lower
vaccination uptake in vulnerable
populations
this rise however is not as rapid as the
case incidence rate
and overall
admissions to intensive care
have not increased significantly
for now the number of debts across the
region is starting
to plateau there is absolutely no
contradiction over there so who geneva
is obviously speaking about
a global perspective
we here in the european region have a
unique situation
first and foremost that once the omicron
wave will subside there will be a large
capital
of immunity be it thanks to the vaccine
or
due to the infection i mean the
continent has in general
quite high vaccination and booster age
number one
number two seasonality is decreasing and
the third one we know that omicron now
that's quite well established is milder
particularly in the vaccinated and the
boosted people
so the pandemic is not over as dr tetros
is rightly telling so but the point that
dr terrell is making that we in the
european region have been supporting
from day one
is the need for international
global
solidarity if 2021 was the year of
vaccine production let 2022 be the year
of vaccine equity